last night we tore the lid off a series
of
off-repeated liberal lies about
president trump's handling of the
coronavirus
the pandemic's fallout though of course
extremely tragic
could have been far worse had he not
shut down travel early and reopened the
economy when he did
hospital systems in a few states were
stretched but not overwhelmed
but given the democrats constant wailing
about what
trump supposedly got wrong we decided
tonight to sketch out
what the situation would have looked
like had joe biden and the democrats
been in charge instead
first biden would not have banned travel
from china
there's no way he would have done that
two months after trump
did just that biden was still worrying
about hurting china's feelings being
overly dismissive
or spreading misinformation is only
going to hurt us and further
advantage the spread of the disease but
neither should we panic
or fall back on xenophobia labeling
covet 19 a foreign virus does not
displace
accountability for the misjudgments that
have been taken
thus far by the trump administration i
was worried about xenophobia not the
virus not only would biden not have
banned travel from china though
he would have effectively rewarded the
ccp for unleashing this plague
by allowing them to continue to steal
our trade secrets and take our jobs
it's clear under biden there'd be no
tariffs
and thus no chinese concessions
some have said a trump stance is a good
one um to counter
china's influence would you keep the
tariffs
no hey look who said trump's idea is a
good one
no he would get rid of the tariffs day
one
a biden presidency is a dream scenario
for the ccp
and given that the who has been pimping
for china for years
how would dealing with them he also
suggested that help
and you know biden wouldn't have banned
travel from europe either even fauci
admitted doing so save lives
but under biden as under obama europe's
feelings on a travel ban would have been
more important
than what was good for americans heaven
forbid
can't offend the french banning all
travel from europe or any other part of
the world
may slow it but as we've seen it will
not
stop it and travel restrictions based on
favoritism
and politics rather than risk will be
counterproductive
i mean you can't make this up and under
biden
illegals they'd keep pouring in and of
course
forget ramped up border enforcement
under biden at all
even european countries like germany
lock down their borders for three months
but joe would never even consider a
crackdown on illegal border crossings
even during a pandemic he'd open the ice
facilities he'd release all detainees
and then maybe ask questions later after
all
what would jorge ramos say trump
campaigned on
um build that wall are you willing to
tear that wall down
no there will not be another foot of
wall constructed
in my administration no of course the
border fence and the walls they're meant
to force foreigners
to formal points of entry where we at
least can do
some minimal screening for illnesses but
biden will always choose
open borders ahead of the health safety
and economic well-being of americans
number three biden would keep you
locked down until at least 2021
and while he's letting millions of
illegal aliens flood the labor markets
during a recession and bring in more
cases of covid
he'd make sure you're still locked down
in your home
and your kids were out of school his
allies in politics
and the press who are messaging biden's
plans
they've spilled the beans if you're not
going to stay home
and you're not going to wear masks in
public we have to enforce
and we will this could have been a very
different summer
if we'd had a better lockdown a longer
lockdown
any concern that you've gone too far in
any way
with the stay-at-home restrictions no
and biden hinted at this himself just
last week
from the beginning of my view the
president has had
given us a false choice he said that
we have to get back to work and
also deal with covet you can't get this
country going again
unless you get coveted under control
you know what that means and number four
biden's lockdowns would obliterate the
recovery
the cost of taking the country back in
the lockdown would be
staggering this idea of more lockdowns
people just throw this
out willy-nilly forgetting the enormous
human
cost as well as the enormous economic
cost the country can't take that
and there's no reason for that biden's
lockdowns
would also lead to more health crises
even with a limited temporary lockdown
things were bad and imagine if it had
continued through most of the year
last month the washington post reported
that suspected overdoses nationally
jumped 18 percent in march
29 in april and 42 percent in may
and lockdowns around the world are
leading to a resurgence of things like
tuberculosis
hiv and malaria the new york times
reporting that a three-month lockdown
across different parts of the world and
a gradual return to normal over 10
months
can result in additional 6.3 million
cases of tb
1.4 million deaths in the worst case
scenario deaths from malaria could
double to 770
000 per year number six
mine would use the pandemic to ram
through far-left policies
and of course the old saying never let a
crisis go to waste
would be biden's pandemic motto and i
truly think
that if we do this right we have an
incredible opportunity
to not just dig out of this crisis but
to fundamentally transform the country
oh there wouldn't be a country left of
course we all know what that means
ramming through every socialist wish
list item
empty out the prisons single-payer
health care government paid child care
the green new deal guaranteed basic
income
and of course reparations and while
president biden went about transforming
our country
he'd of course get a free pass from the
media
no antagonistic interviews with axios
no aggressive questioning from jim
acosta just a lot of gauzy profiles
about
his vice president and how she's a first
and
she's also a global superstar this
laundry list of horribles should make
all americans think about voting for
change
think twice about it in november now
given the violence in the streets and
the leftward turn of the democrats
we know what biden will bring isn't the
type of hope and change that obama
promised 12 years ago
it would be far more radical and now
there's far more at stake
but they hope their lies and their
misdirection will make you forget about
the unparalleled prosperity that we
enjoyed
before the pandemic hit and what we're
on a way to seeing again
under president trump would you rather
go back to that normal
or experience the new normal that
democrats are giving us a glimpse of
in california and in new york and on the
streets of chicago
and baltimore and joe's new society
you'll be poorer less safe less free
and your kids will be less educated and
at that point
a virus will be the least of our
problems
and that's the angle